Này, một sản phúc tâm tổng thủ Mỹ đưa nơi tròa mấy sẽ át thế khoảng 1 chứ vình chăm, đối với chi bản giận nhập khẩu vào nước này.
Điều Mỹ, át thuy nhập khẩu chi bản giã đưa nấu một chăm vình chăm, và nãy bước đi quyền liệt của Washington,
nhăm dạm phụ thuộc tỏng của nguồn cung tự nước ngoài.
Theo tổng thống nước đơn tròa, bể thăm này, lũ tởi một tiêu đưa sản xuất chiếp trở lại Mỹ,
tạo thêm việc làm và bảo đam ăn linh công nghệ.
Huyện Mỹ chỉ chế khoảng 1, 2, 3 lựng chi phần cầu,
giảm mạnh sau với mức 1,5% hồi nămu nhiên trên trăm triếm mây.
Trong khi nhu cầu, với chế bản giã người gặng tăng,
các chuyên giả nhệ này, chính sức mời có thể đã động sâu dọng đến chỗ của mướng công nghệ tăng cầu.
Người át lực lên các nhà sản xuất chiếp nước ngoài,
và bộng nhiều tập đoàn lớn và tinh nhắc vịch chuyển sản xuất phòng Mỹ,
để tránh thử quang cao.